three or four times a year I like to
take mushrooms and go play Slots at the
casinos
yo just because
[Music]
when I take mushrooms a lot of times
when I take mushrooms I just do I rub my
nipples and so I was playing slots and
um I was rubbing my nipples and I was
killing it
all right and I hit a 500 little jackpot
I'm like
[Music]
and I didn't notice this dude was
sitting next to me and he looked at me
and he goes hey and I'm like yeah
and he said you rub your nipples for
good luck
what am I gonna do say no do you know
what I mean so me and this dude sitting
next to each other for like an hour just
rubbing her
at one point he was like it's not
working I'm like you just got to rub him
hard and he was like